one of the interesting aspects of the
story of christ and the christian story
in general is that within the story of
christ you see that christ chose his own
betrayer and this of course is a
testimony to how in a larger sense in
christianity we have the sense that
antichrist will rise out of christianity
will appear as a side effect or a kind
of
a strange deformation of the christian
message and so there are several aspects
to antichrist i'm going to look
especially at one which i called
something like weaponized compassion and
we will see this virgin or this aspect
of antichrist especially in the story of
judas iscariot who is the disciple that
christ chose who ultimately ended up
betraying him
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
and so there are several aspects of
antichrist there are two aspects which
we could see almost as
something like opposed to each other or
two extremes of what antichrist looks
like the one that people usually tend to
uh to look upon is the empire idea of
antichrist or the beast this notion of
rome as being something like uh the
[ __ ] of babylon all this kind of
imagery of of antichrist and it's
especially happened in
the uh the protestant reformation where
you know the notion of the relationship
between the catholic church and rome was
related to a certain extent with the
idea of a kind of
parody of creat of christ and of
christ's message and something like
antichrist and there's something about
that which is interesting because there
is an aspect in the story of christ of
antichrist you could say which is
related to saint peter because
saint peter is of course the one who
denies christ saint peter is also the
one who
although he is the first one to
recognize christ he ultimately refuses
one aspect of christ
refuses for a certain amount of time one
aspect of christ's message which is that
christ must die and when saint peter
wants to oppose that wants to say that
christ will not die on the cross then
that is when christ tells saint peter
get behind me uh satan and so of course
saint peter is important and there's a
very positive aspect of saint peter
which is which is true and which is good
to understand but the story of christ is
very complex and contains all this
subtlety within it and one of the
aspects of saint peter of the strength
of the christian story and the strength
of the
let's say the possibilities of
christianity also has a dark side which
is the possibility of pride the
possibility of
not thinking that christianity is about
self-sacrifice and the willingness to
die um for others and the willingness to
die in general but there is also a flip
side to that image of antichrist which
is that although
um
christ tells us to care for the poor
tells us to tend to the orphan and the
widow and to care for the weak to be
attentive to the margins and to be
attempted to those that are usually
excluded cast out there is also a dark
side to that which is the antichrist
aspect of it which is something that we
could call weaponized compassion
and this version of weaponized
compassion appears in the other disciple
in the story of christ that has to do
with this antichrist aspect and and that
is of course the judas iscariot now
judas iscariot is the one who betrays
christ ultimately betrays him with a
kiss this is related to this weaponized
compassion that we see in the story of
judas and that we will especially see in
the story where mayor of bethany washes
christ's feet so i'm going to read the
text with you and we're going to look at
what's going on in the story and what
that can mean for us especially today
because we are faced with some of that
and uh and it tends to confuse
christians just like also when
christianity is strong and empire-like
it can also
let's say confuse some christians as to
what the real goal of christianity is
and so the text appears in the gospel of
saint john chapter 12 starting at verse
1.
six days before the passover jesus
therefore came to bethany where lazarus
was whom jesus had raised from the dead
so they gave a dinner for him
martha served and lazarus was one of
those reclining with him at table
mary therefore took a pound of expensive
ointment made from pure nard and
anointed the feet of jesus and wiped his
feet with her hair the house was filled
with the fragrance of the perfume but
judas iscariot one of his disciples who
was about to betray him said
why was this ointment not sold for 300
denarii and given to the poor he said
this
not because he cared for the poor but
because he was a thief
and having charge of the money bag he
used to help himself to what was put
into it
jesus said leave her alone so that she
may keep it for the day of my bureau for
the day of my burial for the poor you
always have with you but you do not
always have me and so what's going on in
this story
we have an image of a woman who takes
very expensive
takes something very expensive and
focuses it on worship now we could
understand that as many things of course
we can understand it in general of the
idea of creating beauty in order to
worship god we could also understand it
in in terms of the amount of attention
the amount of time and resources and um
valuable things that we put into the
service of worshiping christ
and so the trick that judas wants to
take is he wants to take a good which is
caring for the poor now of course caring
for the poor is a good not only is it a
good but it is a good that christ
himself has asked us to do good christ
is constantly telling people to to care
for the poor and to help the weak but
he's trying to make that good into the
highest good and this is where there is
a problem and so he tells the woman that
he she should not have used this
expensive thing this precious thing
to worship christ but that she should
have used it and sold it and given it to
the poor now
what's interesting
in in this is this is why i called it
weaponized compassion
because ultimately judas doesn't care
for the poor
what judas wants is to acquire power for
himself and so he wants her to sell this
for money so that he can dip into the
money bag and take the money for himself
now of course this is very specific in
the story but you can understand that in
many ways which is that many people
can use compassion
or use compassion as a weapon in order
to acquire power for themselves now this
is a temptation which is becoming
stronger and stronger in the christian
church it is something which is blinding
many christians to some aspects of what
is going on around them and because they
don't know how to react to it there is a
tendency to make people feel guilty
about their own christian values to make
them feel as if those very christian
values the very christian beliefs they
have is somehow
a compromise in compassion
and that if they were truly
compassionate they would actually
sacrifice their own christian beliefs
the ultimate version of something like
this is in the movie silence which many
of you have probably seen
in this movie a christian missionary is
sent to japan
and
the christian missionary is faced with a
serious problem which is that in trying
to support the christian church there
the japanese
authorities realize that
if we torture the missionaries we have a
problem because the missionaries are
willing to die
for their faith but if we torture other
people
then
that is putting the right pressure on
the missionaries because their own
values their own compassion will compel
them to deny their faith
in order to preserve the life of others
and so of course i can't imagine being
in that situation it's a horrible
situation to be in and i don't want to
judge anybody who's in this situation
who would have compromised or fallen but
the very fact that this is framed in the
story that in the story there is a sense
in which although the missionary denied
his faith and ended up completely
denying his own belief in christ and his
own attachment to god
ultimately there was something holy
about that very action and it we should
it's shown that in the end when he is uh
when he's done when he's dying and he's
being cremated we see that there's a
little cross hidden on him or something
like that and that is to show that
somehow his the very denial of his faith
was done out of compassion and that this
would be the ultimate christian act in a
way would be to deny your faith
out of compassion and so
you can apply this problem to many many
other things you can apply it of course
right now to many social issues in which
those social issues are related to
things that christians hold dear in
their values but there is a pressure
there is a pressure on christians to
out of compassion to deny their own
stance that is not only have compassion
for for for the weak have compassion for
the sinners have compassion for for for
people who are not able to hold the
standard because who can like no one
none no christian can hold the the
ultimate standard that christ lays out
for us um but that
compromising on your standard would be a
more christian thing to do than to
simply love others and be compassionate
while holding to the highest standard
now there's a place where you see that
happen all the time but there's another
aspect of this which is going on right
now which is related almost directly to
the story of judas and the notion of
compromising worship in the name of
something else compromising worship in
the name of compassion there is a
narrative which is being pushed and
which is very strong and
it's strong because it's also long it's
enduring you know it's been two years
now where people are being told that out
of compa that christians shouldn't
commune and worship together out of
compassion for others that is
that out of a desire to preserve the
weak and to preserve the helpless people
should
which should sacrifice worship and
should not should not
practice the christian practices of
singing together before their god of of
of communing together to the holy
sacraments um and
this is a very very fascinating thing
because you can see that
in a way it is
it is a very strong tool it is a very
strong tool because it dies right into
what christians believe and it dives
right into the christians high values
and tries to set those values up as the
highest above what is more important
which is worship and
and submission to god and you see it
you actually see it very interestingly
you can notice that if you look at the
difference between
pope benedict and pope francis it's very
fascinating because pope benedict wanted
to bring back worship and so he brought
out some old crosses that were in
treasuries and wanted to kind of to show
the beauty with investments and this
kind of beautiful aspect of the
christian liturgical services and
christian christian worship and he was
eviscerated he was eviscerated by the
media eviscerated by people ultimately
who hate christianity let's be honest
but nonetheless there was a matter in
which people
gobbled it up and people completely gave
in to this narrative and now here comes
uh pope francis who is the very opposite
who
who tends to
let's say play down the worship aspect
of the church and play up the social
aspect of the church play up the idea of
helping the poor and there's absolutely
nothing wrong of course it is wonderful
for christians to help the poor but the
notion that we should the notion that
worshipping christ
is somehow bad and that putting valuable
things in the service and val and and
worship of god is somehow
is somehow horrible and and uh and
disconnected um whereas helping the poor
is something that everybody loves and
everybody find is beautiful i think is
definitely
an issue and it's an issue that
although i sympathize with christians
who struggle
to see the normal hierarchy this is
actually the normal hierarchy of being
this is really representing the manner
in which attention to the highest
worship of god you know placing yourself
in the right position towards god on
together and alone and together into
communion and you know engaging in the
liturgical dance engaging in the grand
singing and dancing of of worship is
more important than the social actions
of
of of the church
and of course i know some people are
going to watch this and going to get
angry and think that i am somehow
diminishing or or bringing down the idea
of of helping the poor and if of course
not i spent seven years of my life as a
volunteer in africa in the desire just
to serve christ in that manner but
nonetheless i i
still need to
reemphasize the the natural the normal
hierarchy of things which is that if you
try to to to sacrifice the top part for
the second part you are going to break
down and you can see that in many of the
churches that have embraced social
justice no matter how they phrase it as
their highest value higher than their
creed higher than their their own uh
original beliefs higher than the
the values which was which were given to
them you know from from from the
apostles all the way then and they're
willing to even sometimes criticize
scripture criticize you know the saints
in order to bring about this social
justice transformation that they want
that's not going to work it's going to
break down it's going to lead to a
breakdown because it doesn't follow the
normal
if you focus on secondary goods as the
highest good no matter how good
it is
it will ultimately lead to uh to a
breakdown one of the key ways to
recognize if what is being used or what
is being promoted is something like
weaponized compassion is to look at the
power aspect because one of the
ways that we can see it in the story of
judas is that
judas is telling someone else
to be compassionate
in and is reproaching someone else
for not being compassionate with the
purpose of gaining power for themselves
and so this is the best way to see
whether or not uh this is weaponized
compassion and i think that we have seen
plenty of that in the past two years we
have seen plenty of authorities uh tell
us that we need to act in this or that
way in order to be compassionate
compassionate and what's interesting is
that you know on the one hand there's
this idea that you are not being
compassionate you are being selfish by
not doing this or that um but then when
you look behind you the same the same
authorities telling you that are holding
a massive baseball bat over your head
and the consequence for not being
compassionate is that you will feel the
brunt of their raw power on you and you
also notice that ultimately the the
action that they want you to pose is to
the increase of their power on you and
the increase to their power on others
and so this is the way in which you can
recognize weaponized compassion it's
that it is ultimately a making you feel
bad about something
uh in order to acquire power for the
people who are promoting this um
compassion is something which is freely
given compassion is something which we
should always be examining ourselves to
see whether or not we are being
compassionate and what is the motivation
of our actions we should not be trying
to impose compassion on others this is
something which you do not see in the
christian story you know that is
there is no law towards compassion there
is no rule which makes you compassionate
you can follow all the rules you want
compassion is a disposition of the heart
compassion is the disposition of the
person it is not about rules and about
following this or that thing you could
act in ways that look very compassionate
on the outside and are very selfish
inside and vice versa and so compassion
is not something which is
subject to the law it is something which
is subject to the heart and this is of
course the very difference that christ
brings uh to us which is the difference
between the externals and the external
law which is useful and helpful and the
the uh the inner true reason of why
someone is acting and so when you see
someone or when you see an organization
try to impose compassion by law or try
to make you feel as if uh you know by
not being compassionate you are going to
receive the full brunt of the modern
state then we have a serious problem and
so
of course i do not want to say that
there isn't also the other aspect of
antichrist which is the
the aspect of of uh
of believing that christianity is a
political weapon believing that
christianity is a is a tool for
nationalism all these things exist and
they exist now let's be honest uh the
the the prideful aspect of the uh of the
of the antichrist but the other aspect
the weaponized compassion one um is an
aspect which i think is more
misunderstood today and it would be
helpful for us to understand that as we
continue to face the crisis that we are
dealing with
you know that we've been dealing it with
for the past few years and so i hope
this was helpful to help you understand
some aspects of this pattern and uh i'll
talk to you very soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support